los familiares de víctimas de violencia
policial se unieron en manifestaciones
por el primer aniversario de la muerte
de georg floyd piden que los
legisladores aprueben una ley para la
reforma policial que podría prevenir más
muertes
un año después todavía rogamos que
cambien las leyes
el presidente by den también urge al
congreso que apruebe la ley llamada
george floyd los senadores no se ponen
de acuerdo en puntos claves del texto
incluida la llamada inmunidad
cualificada los republicanos no quieren
firmar la ley no creen que oficiales de
policía individuales deberían ser
responsabilizados por sus actos en el
trabajo y eso es un obstáculo
los que apoyan la ley argumentan que la
policía se ha vuelto más violenta e
impune mientras que sus críticos
denuncian que los oficiales son tratados
injustamente
creo que el porcentaje de policías en
todo el mundo que son malos es muy
pequeño y es necesario que los
confrontemos y los eche más que yo pero
siento que la mayoría estamos aquí
haciendo lo correcto por las razones
correctas y tratando de ayudar a todo el
mundo sin importar el color de su piel
varios estados han decidido prohibir o
limitar estrictamente el uso de las
maniobras de asfixia desde la muerte de
floyd su asesinato despertó protestas
masivas en todo eeuu y el mundo
la condena al policía que lo mato
derecho bing se vivió como un momento
trascendental en la lucha por la
justicia racial en el país